aux confins de la chine la ville de
gongshan s'éveille doucement
avant d'attaquer le travail cours de
danse collectif pour détendre les
petites mains de la croissance chinoise
on
[Musique]
il est 7 heures du matin est l'unique
taxis collectifs en partance pour la
frontière birmane se prépare à un voyage
éprouvant
fang rentrer au village il va retrouver
sa grand mère l'une des dernières
représentantes de l'ethnie des lys ou
mais là haut il lui rapporte un cadeau
de prix un cochon pure race qui servira
à la reproduction
mais vu l'état de la route il a peur que
son animal se blesse pendant le voyage
sert bien la cage de mon cochon faut pas
qu'ils tombent
de toute façon il va être malade comme
tout le monde tu connais la route
fais attention des précieux gratuite
s'il meurt je te préviens tu me le
rembourse près de la frontière birmane
il est quasiment impossible de trouver
de l'essence zhang le chauffeur en
rapporte toujours un bidon au village il
est sûr de pouvoir le vendre le double
du prix
[Musique]
depuis que la chine a pris son envol
économique il y a trente ans le réseau
routier s'est considérablement développé
le gouvernement a ouvert des routes dans
les zones les plus reculées des travaux
titanesques pour désenclaver des
villages isolés où seuls les cheveux
vous pouvez assurer le ravitaillement
on va mettre environ sept heures pour
parcourir les 96 km la route qui mène au
village de phong reste l'une des plus
périlleuses de chine zhang
le chauffeur l'empreinte une fois par
semaine
le trajet va être difficile oh oui
terrible la route est dangereuse
récemment il ya eu un accident un enfant
est mort mais ne t'inquiète pas je
conduis sur cette route depuis six ans
maintenant
[Musique]
cela fait déjà une heure que le taxi
collectif a quitté la grande ville de
gongshan et le bitume a déjà laissé
place à la piste
premières secousses premier croisement
et première mauvaise nouvelle
salut l'ami attention il ya un énorme
embouteillage là au hasard que ce qui se
passe c'est bloqué il ya un éboulement
sur la route oui la route est instable
et les éboulements fréquents impossible
de continuer sans prendre ses
précautions
il faut prévenir un proche et lui
indiquer sa position exacte sur la route
au cas où les secours devraient
intervenir
j'ai ici c'est le dernier endroit où le
téléphone peuvent encore capté voyez
chine vend là
[Musique]
cherry ne t'inquiète pas à la route est
bloquée au niveau du col mais les
villageois vont la dégager avec de la
dynamite
tu sembles inquiet non ça arrive souvent
mais quand c'est trop grave
on peut rester bloquée jusqu'à deux
jours regarde c'est là où les roulements
et 3400 mètres lama
[Musique]
le taxi disparaît dans les nuages
la route devient étroite
les falaises vertigineuses
[Musique]
quand tu conduis sur cette route il faut
que ta voiture soit en parfaite état
revient bien vérifier tes frein est à
colonne de direction et surtout tu ne
dois pas être fatigué pour rester bien
concentré car si tu fais le malin tu
tombes direct dans le ravin
[Musique]
broc à l'ombre c'est dans ce tunnel qui
lie à l'éboulement
[Musique]
et qu'est ce que vous allez faire
on n'en sait rien il faut qu'on aille
voir plus loin
apparemment il ya du monde
[Musique]
le tunnel a été creusé dans les années
80 mais il n'a jamais été terminée cela
fait trente ans que les habitants de la
vallée prennent des risques à chaque
fois qu ils l'empruntent 400 m de danger
surtout pendant la mousson
quand la roche est fragilisé par les
infiltrations d'eau
et attention rouler plus doucement
c'est difficile des roues glisse
[Musique]
voilà c'est ici que les pierres sont
tombées on va voir ce que l'on peut
faire
si on peut aider on descend on descend
vous avez vu ce chantier toutes ces
pierres et bien elles sont tombées de là
haut c'est le plafond du tunnel qui
s'est écroulé
allez vas-y casse frappe plus fort s'il
te plaît bon là bas c'est dégagé par
contre ici les camions vont pas passer
on n'est pas prêt de sortir
[Applaudissements]
par là s'il te plaît
et la lumière qui a coupé son moteur on
ne peut pas travailler sans lumière
redémarrez s'il vous plaît pour ne pas
vider les batteries avec leurs phares
les conducteurs laisse tourner les
moteurs dix hommes travaillent
d'arrache-pied depuis le début de la
matinée dans les gaz d'échappement et la
poussière avec le risque que les parois
s'écroulent à nouveau
fang et un autre passager parti en
éclaireur inspecter la sortie du tunnel
à l'extérieur aussi il ya du monde qui
attend il y en a plein tu n'aurais pas
une cigarette vous attendez depuis
longtemps moi c'est moi je viens juste
d'arriver
vous prenez souvent le tunnel je fais le
trajet trois fois par semaine des
éboulements y en a tout le temps mais
cette année c'est pire avec ces grosses
plus qui ne s'arrête jamais l'eau
s'infiltre et le tunnel s'effondre
habitué à voyager sur cette route
imprévisible les passagers prennent leur
mal en patience
[Musique]
à l'intérieur du tunnel
les camions tente un passage en force
ça avance
comme à droite
attention à ta roue l' asie rotule
recule recule recule ses gaffes à ton
rétro là
[Applaudissements]
non non laisse tomber tu ne passera
jamais
[Applaudissements]
le camion ne passe pas il faut dégager
ces poutres ces poutres ce sont les
seuls renforts du tunnel et pourtant au
mépris du danger pour élargir le passage
ils vont en abattre quelques unes au
risque de provoquer un nouvel éboulement
phong dirigent l'opération
on n'a plus le choix il faut couper ses
poutres c'est le seul moyen d'élargir le
passage
[Applaudissements]
vas-y avance allait encore encore n'ai
pas peur
[Applaudissements]
sans les poutres les conducteurs sont
inquiets ils ont peur que les vibrations
des camions fasse trembler trop fort les
parois du tunnel
[Musique]
après deux heures d'attentes le taxi
collectif s'échappe à son tour
il lui reste encore 50 km à parcourir
pour rejoindre le village mais il n'a
pas encore franchi la partie la plus
éprouvante de cette route
[Musique]
le taxi collectif est malmené par la
piste
comme ses occupants
le chauffeur doit redoubler d'efforts
pour garder le contrôle de sa voiture et
surtout faire en sorte que les secousses
ne décroche pas son chargement empilés
sur le toit
qu'est ce qui se passe quelque chose est
tombé attends je vais voir assez le
cochon mais qu'est ce qu'on fait bah
faut le mettre dans la voiture sur le
siège arrière
ah non pas d'animal dans mon taxi passe
moi le cochon s'il te plaît donnez-moi
doucement attends attends regarde ton
animal regarde le bien il saigne
effectivement dans sa chute le cochon
s'est blessé à la croûte
c'est à cause des secousses
il a un peu souffert et ça ira ouais
ne vous inquiétez pas il ne va pas nous
bloquer longtemps ce camion
allez c'est bon ça passe
en ce moment des camions transporteurs
de bois comme celui ci on en croise
beaucoup sur la route et c'est un espoir
pour la vallée depuis quelques années le
gouvernement tente de repeupler ses
campagnes désertées par les paysans
beaucoup sont partis travailler en ville
sur les grands chantiers de construction
ou dans les usines qui tournent 24
heures sur 24 pour le monde entier
mais depuis la crise le travail se fait
rare et les paysans retournent vers
leurs villages
alors pour les inciter à rester le
gouvernement a lancé un grand programme
dans la région une maison gratuite pour
les plus pauvres c'est ça le communisme
on offre une maison à ceux qui en ont
besoin
les maisons réservées aux plus pauvres
se trouve juste à l'entrée du village de
phong le taxi collectif aura mis 15
heures au lieu des six prévus pour
parcourir les 100 km de pistes
[Musique]
vous êtes content d'être arrivé
ah oui on est heureux d'être là mais je
suis plein de courbatures
voilà le bidon d'essence a fui en a
partout moi le bidon pratiquement vide
rien d'ici la fi sur tout les sens et
sorti par là pourquoi c'est si grave
je ne vais pas pouvoir faire le plein de
ma moto déçu cheng va faire cadeau du
peu d'essence qui lui reste mais pour
ces 15 heures de voyage
il va toucher 100 yens par passager soit
au total 60 euros une bonne paye qui
représente plus d'une fois le salaire
moyen dans la région elle cochon comment
va-t-il il va bien mon cochon un peu de
repos un petit traitement et ce sera bon
[Musique]